- Le mont Blanc, en France,
perd un peu plus chaque année
de sa majestuosité.
Skieurs et alpinistes
le constatent : le glacier a
reculé de près d'un kilomètre.
L'épaisseur de la Mer de Glace
a diminué d'environ 200 mètres
depuis 50 ans.
Au pied de la montagne,
on se creuse les méninges pour
freiner la fonte, mais aussi
pour diversifier le tourisme
parce que la neige se fera
de plus en plus rare.
Le Québec non plus n'est pas
épargné par les changements
climatiques. Prenez par exemple
ce cocktail météo de la fin
du mois d'avril qui empêche
la prolongation de la saison
de ski. Dans plusieurs régions,
on se pose la question :
comment maximiser l'utilisation
de la montagne et les retombées
économiques? Ici, par exemple,
au mont Grand-Fonds,
dans Charlevoix, on mise
sur la randonnée pédestre.
- C'est vraiment une volonté
de développer le quatre saisons.
- Pour le directeusme
Charlevoix, la vitalité
de la région en dépend.
MITCHELL DION, directeur
général, Tourisme Charlevoix
- Ça vient renforcer le lien
aussi avec les commerçants
locaux, donc des partenariats
plus à l'année qu'on peut faire.
Puis, bref, c'est toute la vie
économiqéficie
d'un virage quatre saisons.
CAROLINE PROULX,
ministre du Tourisme, Québec
- La majorité de nos montagnes
au Québec sont développées
autour d'une seule activité.
On pense tout de suite
au ski alpin.
- Mais on ne peut plus
tout miser sur le ski, pense
tre Caroline Proulx,
qui invite neuf régions à
lui soumettre un "Plan montagne
quatre saisons", financé
à hauteur de 11 millions $.Une s
a conclu que d'ici 2050,
l'industrie touristique située
proche du fleuve connaîtra
plus de difficultés avec
les précipitations de pluie.
- Ça pourrait être de développer
du arbre en arbre du côté
de l'Estrie dans les stations.
Ça peut être de construire
des pôles d'observation.
Et en plus, on vient répondre
à un enjeu de main-d'oeuvre,
parce qu'on est capable
d'attacher, donc, des gens
sur quatre saisons.
JOSÉE GERVAIS, propriétaire,
boulangerie Pains d'exclamation!
- Novembre, décembre,
c'est mort. Ça recommence
un petit peu en ma
vers la fête des Patriotes.
Ça fait une gestion de personnel
qui est assez difficile aussi.
- Pour garder ses employés,
la propriétaire de cette
boulangerie de La Malbaie
souhaite plus de touristes
au printemps et à l'automne.
- Encore faut-il avoir
le personnel pour gérer tout
à l'année. Je viens contredire
un peu ce que j'ai dit, là!
- En fait, pour qu'un Plan
Montagne quatre saisons
fonctionne, il ne
doute pour elle qu'il faudra
aussi un plan pour contrer
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Qué